I saw one conspiracy which was like
there's a Mr Maxwell but he died in like
the 90s or something nobody knows where
his billions went but then Jeffrey
Epstein popped up with all these
billions oh who's married or with the
daughter of Maxwell Jeffrey Epstein then
dies mysteriously where do his billions
go well he dies around the same time
that Sam bankman freed just pops up with
all these billions so now sandbag
mccreed has all these billions in 2019
which he supposedly made by Arbitrage
trading Bitcoin for three and a half
years you don't make nine billion
dollars in three years by Arbitrage
trading Bitcoin so I feel like the
establishment or whatever cost him the
money to have him as a front for the
elites then donates the money he becomes
like the crypto arm for the
establishment so I feel like he's one of
them unless he calls them all out then I
think he could get Epstein